Director Joss Whedon blew the doors off the
superhero movie world with The Avengers, but
his follow-up, Avengers: Age of Ultron, kind
of left...a few things to be desired.
From weird plot points to mysterious helicarriers
that pop up right when you need them, here
are a few of the dumb things about Avengers:
Age of Ultron everyone just ignored.
​Why is Stark still Iron Man?
Before Age of Ultron, the last time we saw
Tony Stark was in his solo flick Iron Man
3.
Stark spends most of that film dealing with
post-traumatic stress from the alien invasion
in The Avengers.
He eventually realizes he doesn't need the
armor and walks off into the sunset with Pepper
Potts.
Nice.
Great ending.
So long, Tony...
So then, why is Tony flying around in a shiny
new suit when Age of Ultron rolls around?
We never get an answer.
And Age of Ultron basically ignores all the
character development and growth we saw in
Iron Man 3.
Why?
Well, probably so he can go and make the movie's
villain by accident.
Speaking of which...
​Tony Stark is wildly irresponsible
Ultron might get top billing, but seriously:
Tony Stark is the real villain of this movie.
He tinkers with technology and magic he doesn't
understand, and then just sets the whole thing
to run on autopilot — so he can go party.
And then he's somehow surprised when an evil
AI is born from the all-powerful Infinity
Stone.
Even worse, when Captain America calls him
out on his idiocy, he gets all defensive and
shifts the blame.
Sure, his intentions may have been noble,
but building some fail-safes into his insanely
dangerous experiments might have been even
nobler.
Or at least run some antivirus software or
something, dude.
​Missing in inaction
The big party scene early in the run time
was one of the best moments in this film,
serving as a fun reminder that this is a big,
expansive universe.
But...where did Falcon and War Machine disappear
to once the action started?
At least War Machine shows up right at the
end, but Falcon is still nowhere to be found.
Wouldn't having an extra flying guy be useful
during this gigantic battle that threatened
an entire city?
And it'd be one thing if these characters
hadn't showed up early on.
But c'mon!
They're already in the movie!
What could Falcon possibly have had to do
that'd be more important than helping save
the entire freaking world?
"Too legit.
Too legit to quit."
Oh, well, never mind.
What the helicarrier?
In Captain America: The Winter Soldier, Cap
forces SHIELD's Helicarriers to blow themselves
up.
And then the whole SHIELD organization disbands.
But right when the Avengers need it most,
boom!
A helicarrier comes out of nowhere to save
the day!
That's not only really convenient, it also
makes no sense.
The helicarrier was eventually explained away
in an episode of Marvel's Agents of SHIELD,
but expecting people to watch a supplemental
video to explain the plot contrivances of
Avengers: Age of Ultron is even dumber than
this random helicarrier.
Couldn't they have found some other way to
get around?
"You know, I have the authority to downgrade
your ass to a Winnebago."
"I'm aware of that, sir."
Logicbuster
Fans have been clamoring for a straight-up
Iron Man vs. Hulk fight ever since the MCU
became a thing.
And Age of Ultron delivered in spades, thanks
to Iron Man's Hulkbuster armor, which is so
powerful it allows Tony to go toe to toe with
the big green guy.
Awesome, right?
But if the Hulkbuster armor is that amazing,
why doesn't he just… use it all the time?
It seems silly to develop something this awesome
and only use it for this one specific fight.
Y'know, maybe the crazy-powerful Hulkbuster
Armor could've come in handy when the Avengers
had to battle a certain murderous robot trying
to destroy the world.
Speaking of which...
​Ultron's dumb plan
So Ultron is an infinitely advanced AI with
a bloodlust.
He wants to take out the Avengers...and also
all of humanity.
Hey, go big or go home, right?
He quickly gets loose inside the internet,
and though we're told he can't access the
nuclear launch codes thanks to Jarvis fighting
him off, there are still a lot of other things
he could mess with.
How about the electrical grid?
The water supply?
The fuel supply?
Traffic lights?
Air traffic controllers?
Why not hijack every piece of tech used by
the Avengers and turn it against them?
The list goes on.
But instead of causing global panic and making
toasters kill people, Ultron decides to...build
a humanoid super-body, recruit a couple of
freaky super-rave-kids to help him fight,
and then drop a city on the Avengers?
That seems...needlessly complicated.
And stupid.
"What's the vibranium for?"
"I'm glad you asked that, because I wanted
to take this time to explain my evil plan."
Look, Ultron.
You may be, like, a super genius robot guy
or whatever.
But when your plan is officially dumber than
the plot of Maximum Overdrive, you messed
up.
"Uggh!"
"What the hell?!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!